[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
hello this is sky news today it's one
o'clock the headlines
cutting out russia u.s president joe
biden announces a gas deal with the eu
to try and end europe's dependence on
russian energy
new pictures emerge from inside the
mariopol theatre bombed by russia as
eyewitnesses claim as many as 300 people
were killed
diplomacy continues as boris johnson
speaks to the president of china for
nearly an hour about ukraine
too late to stop the war ukraine's
president zelensky criticizes the eu for
acting too slowly over sanctions as
ukrainian forces fight back around the
capital keefe
and cancel culture president putin
accuses the west of trying to wipe out
russian culture
[Music]
afternoon the united states and the
european union have announced a new deal
to try and reduce europe's dependence on
russian gas president biden has promised
to supply an extra 15 billion cubic
metres of liquefied natural gas to the
eu this year at the moment it gets
almost 40 percent of its natural gas
from russia
here's how the deal was announced
we're coming together to reduce europe's
dependence on russian energy
putin has issued russia's energy
resources to coerce and manipulate its
neighbors that's how he's used it
he's used the profits to drive his war
machine
that's why earlier this month i
announced the united states would ban
all imports of russian energy to make it
clear the american people would not be
part of subsidizing putin's brutal
unjustified war against people ukraine
at the time
i noted that
we were able to take this step when
others could not because the united
states is a net exporter of energy with
a strong domestic industry
and the united states welcomed the
european union's powerful statement
earlier this month committing to rapidly
reduce its dependence on russian gas
today
we've agreed on a joint game plan toward
that goal
while accelerating our progress toward a
secure clean energy future
this initiative focuses on two core
issues one
helping europe reduces dependency on
russian gas as quickly as possible
secondly
reducing europe's demand for gas overall
to address the first point the united
states together with our international
partners
they're we're going to work to ensure an
additional
1 15 1 5 15 billion cubic meters of
liquefied natural gas lng for europe
this year
and as the year as the eu works to
discontinue it buying russian gas well
before 2030 it will also will also work
to
ensure additional eu market demand for
50 billion cubic meters of lng from the
united states annually by 2030.
to accomplish this the european
commission is going to work with the
member states to store gas across the
continent
to build more infrastructure to receive
lng
and to take steps to increase the
efficiency of gas
this build out
this buildup will occur in a way that
consists is consistent with not in
conflict with the zero net zero climate
goal we should with that we're shooting
for
the transatlantic partnership stands
stronger and more united than ever
and we are determined to stand up
against russia's brutal war
this war will be a strategic failure for
putin
as you know we aim to reduce this
dependency on russian fossil fuels and
to get rid of it
and this can only be achieved
through of course first of all
investment in renewables
but also through additional gas supplies
including lng deliveries
so we want as europeans to diversify
away from russia
towards suppliers that we trust that our
friends and that are reliable
in brussels earlier today and you're
looking at pictures now of air force one
landing in poland this is the second
stop
in his trip so he's now landed in poland
that's ahead of a visit to a town on the
border with ukraine uh where he's going
to be meeting some of those troops but
also of course
one of those towns that has seen that
huge influx of refugees desperate men
women and children civilians fleeing
from ukraine into poland which has
received millions of the refugees in the
weeks since the invasion there so that
is air force one president joe biden
landing in poland after his visit to
brussels
well in the last hour the russian
president vladimir putin has accused the
west of trying to cancel russian culture
including great composers such as
tchaikovsky and rachmaninoff
they're not trying to cancel
our country i'm talking about the
progressive discrimination of everything
to do with russia this trend that's
unfolding in a number of western states
with the
full um
neglect sometimes encouragements of
western cultures
that they're now
engaging in the cancer culture they're
even uh removing tchaikovsky stakeover
character
posters russian writers and their books
are cancelled there's now
the latest
program to cancel
world literature was conducted by the
nazis in germany 90 years
years ago
we can look now at some of the day's
other developments in the conflict in
ukraine and boris johnson has held a
50-minute phone call with the chinese
president xi jinping about the
situation in ukraine that's as western
leaders call on china to stop supporting
russia
joe biden is arriving in poland this
lunch time and visit a town visiting a
town near the border with ukraine which
is now home to more than two million
ukrainian refugees
and here in the uk the ministry of
defense says that ukraine has managed to
reoccupy towns and defensive positions
up to 21 miles east of the capital kiev
and mariposa city council has said that
according to eyewitness reports about
300 people were killed in the drama
theatre that's after it was bombed by
russian forces last week
the besieged city of maripol in the
southeast of ukraine has suffered some
of the largest losses of life during the
war even before today more than two and
a half thousand people were thought to
have been killed there
targets of russian strikes have included
that theater where hundreds were
sheltering a maternity and children's
hospital as well
but
ukraine is fighting back the latest
british intelligence suggests russia's
advance towards the black seaport city
of odessa in the south is being slowed
by the ukrainian resistance russian
forces are still attempting to
circumvent nearby mikalive
further north ukrainian counter-attacks
have reportedly allowed its forces to
reoccupy towns and defensive positions
up to 22 miles east of kiev
civilians in boris bill the home to an
international airport have been urged to
flee to help ukrainian efforts to clear
russian forces from that area
and meanwhile the ministry of defense
here has
suggested that ukrainian forces are
likely to push russian forces northwest
from kiev towards hommesdale airfield
new picture has emerged from inside the
maripo theatre which has been verified
by sky news
the video that you're looking at now was
filmed on march 16th after the reported
russian strike and it emerged on social
media today
hundreds of civilians are thought to
have been sheltering in the building at
the time of the attack
and people have also been leaving the
city of mikaliv in the south of the
country which is seen as an important
staging post for russia as it tries to
capture the port of odessa
russian shelling was reported to have
hit a psychiatric hospital there earlier
in the week
the u.n refugee agency in ukraine says
more than 3.7 million people have left
ukraine since the conflict began poland
has accepted more than 2.2 million
refugees fleeing the conflict and people
are continuing to arrive at the polish
border
seeking safety
well sally lockwood is in the viv and
joins us now and sally
president biden left brussels he's now
touching down in poland where of course
we've seen the extraordinary influx of
refugees what do you think the purpose
of that visit is
well a show of support to neighbouring
countries of course who are shouldering
so much of the burden in terms of the
humanitarian crisis that's unfolding
in ukraine
and he will be also paying a visit to
u.s military which is based in poland
as well we also understand that
president biden will be meeting some of
the ukrainian refugees
who've fled to poland more than 2
million as you say who've left ukraine
now and gone into poland but more than
three and a half million in total have
left the country and in the space of the
last month
a quarter of the ukrainian population a
country of 44 million people are now
homeless and on the move in search of
safety this country really has been
absolutely traumatized in the last four
weeks
of war and to give you another stark
figure sophie half of the country's
children are now homeless too we've seen
a large number of them here in la viv in
western ukraine it's become a bit of a
bottleneck of families passing through
trying to work out where they're moving
on to next whether it's somewhere else
in ukraine to meet up with relatives or
onto
a neighboring country and they're
carrying whatever they can you see
children just sitting on bags of
belongings holding on to their toys or
or their own little little bags and and
they look very very sad indeed it's it's
heartbreaking that these young people
don't have the uh right to feel well
they do have the right to feel safe in
their homes but they don't have that
luxury here in ukraine at the moment
this country really has been completely
upturned in the last four weeks and
president biden
has pledged to take in 100 000
refugees into america he's also pledged
billions of dollars to support
neighboring countries but none of these
things are a quick fix none of these
things are a silver bullet and certainly
none of the sanctions that have been
announced so far have done anything to
deter vladimir putin's invasion uh and
aggression towards this country
we're just looking at the pictures there
of refugees you know children carrying
plastic bags with their whole belongings
in you know a suitcase and i guess in
some ways these are the lucky ones that
people have managed to flee to poland
and the real concern
is those who are trapped in places such
as mario polo it feels as if every day
that we just get more appalling news out
of a city that has been devastated by
the invasion
yeah you're absolutely right sophie
the ground forces the russian ground
forces here haven't done very well at
all certainly keeve hasn't fallen as
many expected in the early days the
government
is still
in power in the country's capital and
they've largely failed in many areas
ukrainian forces even regaining control
of certain areas that they lost
initially
so what have they done when they haven't
been able to take these cities they've
started shelling them
and dropping
bombs on them and there's no more stark
example of that than the city of mario
paul which has been absolutely
devastated in the last four weeks at
least a hundred thousand people remain
trapped there
uh if not far more than that
and of course those images emerging this
morning
of people inside that packed
theater which was being used as a
shelter in mario pole you can see just
how many people are in there and it's
clearly
after the bombing it's people are
covered in dust it looks fairly
destroyed
inside and it's taken more than a week
for those pictures to reach the outside
world sophie and that's something that i
think we really need to remember is that
we're getting very little in the way of
news out of mario paul but that
shouldn't stop the world talking about
it and covering what's happening in that
city the best they can because the
humanitarian crisis there is absolutely
desperate i spoke to
one former resident of mario poll who
managed to escape
i spoke to her this morning she used to
live near that theater
uh and she said that it's got so bad
there she's got relatives still trapped
there and she said she manages to hear
from them every now and then and she
said the first few words that get sent
to her in a text message are i'm alive
and she said that it's not just mass
graves that you're seeing now uh in
mario polls she said that
uh one of her relatives described how
people's arms are hanging from trees it
really doesn't bear thinking about that
food and medical supplies have been
blocked from entering the city for weeks
now the concern is uh if those people
aren't rescued soon people will start
starving
to death one other thing she told me
which was quite shocking is you you will
of course remember the bombing of that
maternity unit in mario pole a couple of
weeks ago well she said that some of the
women
who were in the maternity unit were
taken to the theater and they weren't in
the basement they weren't in the shelter
they were
given dressing rooms uh in the theater
to to stay in and apparently it was that
area of the theater that was hit by that
airstrike some of those women who who
were rescued from the maternity unit
were also in in the theater which
had was clearly marked as having
children inside
uh now
the other big concern at the moment is
actually quieting down in terms of
fighting was perhaps been the quietest
night in terms of fighting so far
in ukraine certainly we haven't had
any air raid sirens here for the last
two days but that hasn't filled people
here with much confidence there is a
concern
that russian forces are regrouping there
is also a very real concern about the
potential use of chemical weapons which
of course president biden has said
would result in nato responding in kind
now no one knows quite what president
biden means by that but certainly it
feels like this war is entering a
concerning second phase
uh thank you so much for the update
sally um sally look with there giving
the
perspective from ukraine and of course
those horrific stories that we still
keep getting from mario paul
uh the theater very clearly showing
children
uh outside in the writing before it was
bombed
well let's get some more now on the call
that we mentioned between the prime
minister and the chinese leader xi
jinping now
uh all important we can go live to
westminster and our political
correspondent ali fortescue ali do we
know yet what was said on the call
we haven't yet received a readout but
i think it was obviously an important
call and it's a complex relationship we
know that the call lasted just over 50
minutes between president xi of china
and boris johnson and we know that it's
the first time that they have spoken
this year
critically the first time they've spoken
since the war in ukraine and
as i say it is a complex relationship
not least because of issues like hong
kong but china what china do next is
going to be absolutely critical for what
happens in ukraine they are a key player
in all of this you'll remember that
extraordinary meeting between president
xi and president putin right at the
start of the olympics before russia had
started their invasion of ukraine where
they talked about their ever closer
friendship no limits to the relationship
they said between the two countries well
now that relationship is being put to
the test we know that president xi has
not publicly condemned what is happening
in ukraine in fact china abstained from
a u.n security council meeting voting um
to condemn putin's actions in ukraine so
um we have we haven't yet seen that
public condemnation the concern is what
might happen next is will russia support
um will
china rather sorry support russia with
weapons that is something that the u.s
are warning russia have asked for will
they provide that military support
yesterday nato clearly outlined that
they do not want that to happen warning
china that putin needs to be isolated
pressure needs to be put on russia and
that is something i'm sure that prime
minister boris johnson will have been
outlining in that call today setting out
the uk's position as i say it is a
complex relationship but it was an
important call at an important moment
sophie
yeah and certainly an important player
at china if there is to be any
diplomatic solution to the war we're
seeing ali thank you
well of course bringing the content off
i call when we get it
well as we've just been reporting and as
sally lockwood has been describing uh
mario paul has suffered some
heavy shelling from russian forces to
say the least tens of thousands of
people are trapped there without basic
necessities like drinking water forcing
thousands to flee if they can and for
many residents their only way out until
now has been to take their chances and
head for zaparilla which is about 140
miles west
our correspondent john sparks spoke to
some of the people arriving at a
makeshift processing center he sent this
report
this unremarkable spot in a place called
zaparisia
means a lot to the people of mario paul
it's a beacon of light in the dazzling
sunshine and it marks the end of a
horrific ordeal
it's really strong bad painful
experience
and now we need to start our life from
from the beginning
they arrive in a procession of battered
looking cars with a sign saying children
in the windows
the journey from mario paul is
relatively short
but it is a dangerous trip and some take
days to complete it
how do you feel
helena and her family have negotiated 15
russian checkpoints
but she and her granddaughter alisa are
safe
i am fine you're fine okay
you've
took six days to get here they ran out
of petrol halfway
but she couldn't spend another minute in
mariopol
i don't know really how to describe it
because you don't know will you be alive
and i mean i don't know will your son
will be alive
oh no
one night
he said to me my son he is 10 years old
sorry
one minute
he asked me
mama will
will i see my birthday in august or no
will i'll be alive and i
didn't know what to say to him
on the other side of the street we found
another convoy of cars hoping to make
the trip back to mario paul
the owners want to pick up family or
friends or bury those killed in the
fighting
alexander's mother lived in a building
that was hit by a shell
and he said he wasn't able to reach her
uh
it's been cold he said very cold i doubt
she's alive
if i find a leg i find a leg but i will
bury her
some families bring their documents and
the clothes on their back
others like the lachenkos have brought
the business
and their business is french bulldogs
and pugs
they've got 50 of them now living in two
vans
you don't have much room back there
36 000 people have passed through this
car park along with a large family of
french bulldogs
their lives have been uprooted their
homes have been destroyed but where
there is life there is hope
john sparks sky news in zappo
rija sparks there while ukrainian forces
have continued to counter-attack against
the russian advance the uk ministry of
defence reports that ukrainian troops
are pushing back russian forces north
west of kyiv and have now managed to
make gains east of the capital too well
joining us now is air marshal phil
osborne the former chief of defence
intelligence a director at universal
defense and security solutions thank you
so much for
uh being with us uh today um i've just
got a little bit of breaking news uh to
bring you because i'm very interested to
get your
perspective on
whether or not you know what the real
situation is on the ground because we
have heard from the russian defense
ministry who has said the main targets
of the first phase of russia's operation
in ukraine are complete
they go on to say that 93 of luhansk
region's territory has been in their
words not mine liberated
and they also then go on to say
that
their focus is going to be on liberating
the donbass region in the future what is
your take
on
what the russian defense ministry or the
foreign ministry is saying here i mean
how much how much credit should we give
these claims
um
russia's been losing the information war
let's be honest um so what we might be
seeing here is is something
to try and take back some of that
initiative they have got an internal
narrative against this special operation
that they need to support and what what
we're hearing i think
is probably much more for internal
consumption than it would be for
external consumption if you like one of
their strategic objectives was
apparently to liberate areas to the to
the east of ukraine and therefore it
probably underlines an internal
narrative i think what we should also
bear in mind though is that russia's
strategic objectives haven't really
changed they've not been successful as
they would expect it to be um
but
but those strategic objectives will
still be there this is one of those
strategic objectives and the defense
ministry talking there about the first
phase of russia's operation in ukraine
being complete
there has been some concern hasn't there
that russian forces may be regrouping i
had foreign secretary lis trust saying
that she thought the talks were
effectively a smoke screen to allow
russia to do that
are you concerned at all about you know
a second phase that we could be entering
into
i think we're already into the second
phase to be honest i think you're right
around
a realignment perhaps a re-emphasis to
the east and the south
russia has been unsuccessful
by its standards in the north
i don't think what we're seeing here is
anything that changes a perspective that
says this is not going to be over
quickly this this is this is going to be
a long haul for russia but obviously
also for ukraine and therefore the west
support is is ever more pivotal i'm
interested to talk to you about what is
happening in the north as well because
you know we have seen
these stories of ukrainian forces
effectively retaking territory from
russia how significant do you think
that is do you think they'll be able to
hold those positions and i think your
last point is is is really important um
it's fantastic from the ukrainian
perspective um to have successful
counter-attacks particularly in those
areas around kiev underlining that
probably the russian objective to
encircle keep just isn't possible
um it'll be great for their morale it'll
be really bad for russian morale let's
be honest it also forces the russians
into being more defensively aware it
slows down their momentum etc
but i think we have to be really careful
to see that in a wider context has
widespread ukrainian success it's a big
deal to shift from defense where they've
been outstanding into campaign-wide
offense trying to support that across
the region is a completely different
logistical challenge and would put
immensely different levels of pressure
on the ukrainian armed forces that's
interesting and i guess the other
challenge
is
the fact that russia appears to be using
ever more devastating tactics in
effectively just shelling civilians
right targeting the civilian population
rather than necessarily the ground war
um
russia's ability to execute agile
warfare has been shown to be
weak arguably non-existent therefore
it's gone back to what it knows best
what is demonstrated
elsewhere
and we ought to be clear russia can
escalate its conventional
destruction so what do you mean by that
what would that um it can bring much
more conventional firepower to bear i
mean the tragedy we're seeing in mario
poll um it could get worse
conventionally so there is this
debate around chemical weapons um in the
last 24 hours or so has has been more
prominent but i don't think we should
look sight of the fact that conventional
heavy artillery uh can wreak devastation
the like of which hasn't been seen in
europe for decades okay um gonna have to
leave it there on that extremely uh
somber thought thank you so much for you
know sitting here and explaining
what's happening in ukraine thank you
you're watching sky news today coming up
30 days into a russian invasion we'll be
getting the latest from the deputy head
of office for the president of ukraine
[Music]
[Music]
look at that sheet of flakes and it's
moving this way
and over there is dover we track the
changes happening to our world right now
i think it's a procession of the taliban
there they are right here would you as
prime minister be able to look them in
the face let's have a look at both of
those two things i just want to say
thank you for having the courage to
speak to us we do genuinely believe in
what we do to show the truth
i thought there was an astonishing story
there
well let's get the latest on what's
happening in ukraine itself now shall we
joining us now is igor joshka the deputy
head of the office of the president of
ukraine thank you very much for being
with us we're getting different messages
from the ukrainians who are talking
about
retaking positions from russia and also
from the russian defense ministry who
are claiming that the objectives of
phase one have been accomplished in
ukraine
what is your assessment of where we are
now currently
well their original objectives were to
capture major parts of ukraine and major
cities of ukraine within the first three
five days of their so-called special
operations they call it before the time
being having the 30th day of war a month
of war we see that they haven't managed
to capture
any major cities just manage to encircle
to besiege some smaller cities in
southern and eastern ukraine but even in
those cities uh they are not controlling
the situation uh because they try to
install the occupation authorities but
in vain people are coming out on the
streets with the protests carrying
national flags international anthem they
have been arrested they have been in
forcefully deported to russia like in
the city mario
when fifteen thousand fifteen um
hundred people were just you know
forcefully deported to the russian
federation
and that's what happened in bergans for
instance for instance yesterday they
they captured
port but when uh where our armed forces
managed to blow up
the big
transportation vessel uh carrying out
400 manpower and several uh hundreds of
uh tanks and uh armored machines so
they're not controlling anything and yes
right you are where our armed forces are
taking back some territories as it's
happening around outskirts of kiev some
smaller cities and villages which were
captured previously by russian armed
forces are being taken back or the armed
forces of russian federation are
encircled in some parts of these cities
so after 30 days of operation we are
doing fine on the ground yes we need a
support on our partners bringing back to
us the weaponry and necessary equipment
but
not in any case the
targets of russian armed forces are even
closer to being fulfilled
how concerned are you that if the war on
the ground is not going as putin wants
the russian forces will resort to
more
targeting of civilians we've obviously
seen it already in places like mario
paul
that's what why what they are doing the
last two or three weeks having not
achieved their military uh goals uh
and they were
you know announcing in the beginning
that they're fighting only against
military infrastructure and armed forces
now they are fighting against women
children civilians the airstrike and
kindergartens schools maternity
hospitals a drama theater he was in
mario several days ago and yes
unfortunately they will continue to do
this they are now firing this uh
high-level missiles supersonic missiles
like caliber hitting the targets of
civilian origin i mean what has to do
with school against the russian armed
forces et cetera and unfortunately they
will do it i mean uh kiev is practically
every night bombarded by by by by this
missiles and look what they are doing
they are striking the air missiles uh
from the planes from the jets around the
black sea
across the whole ukraine so for them not
to be you know
detected but out but
by our anti-air uh warfare systems
unfortunately this was this is a mean
tactic this is a barbarous tactic this
is an act of a genocide but there are
signs that it will continue to do this
i'm interested to get your take on
whether the west is doing enough to
support ukraine and president biden
in brussels today announcing this deal
to try and supply more uh gas to the eu
but it's only around 10 of what they
currently buy from russia
do you think europe is doing enough
to try and ramp up the pressure on
russia
no i don't think europe is doing enough
in terms of sanctions uh we have already
four packages of sanctions introduced by
the european union but unfortunately is
far from being enough
it's not
it's too slow and you know a little bit
uh
doesn't bring us an immediate result
because any concrete sanctions uh should
bring immediate result uh to russian
economy let it be a tailor-made
sanctions but a very you know uh
swift and quick uh sanctions to be
influenced in the russian economy we're
talking about for instance right you are
about import of russian gas oil and coal
this is very really what needed
what we don't have still from the
european union or closing the european
ports for instance for russian versus or
freezing the russian accounts in the
european basin confiscating the the
assets or disconnecting all the russian
banks from swedes not only just seven
minor banks or uh
putting sessions on politically exposed
persons in russia or abolition visas for
russian citizens so this is this all is
on the table of european leaders my
president appealed yesterday uh during
the summit of the european council to
all the leaders saying that thank you
for what you are doing but it's far from
being enough
you're saying that it's far from enough
given the current level of support the
fact that it doesn't feel as if
europe is anytime soon can to completely
stop its supply of uh russian
gas given the fact that a no-fly zone
has been effectively ruled out
how long can ukraine hold on
well ukraine will hold on your plan
ukraine will survive and ukraine will
struggle but right you are without this
without the no-fly zone it's much more
harder and much more difficult for us
because people are dying people are
dying because of air missiles because of
their airstrikes because of ballistic
missiles flying over our heads with
absolutely open sky so yes closing the
sky would bring this uh war almost
immediately to an end because you know
we're doing
more or less good on the ground and and
with the support again of our western
partners with the support of weapons and
ammunition which we're having by the way
uh we would do and we would win but yes
uh closing this guy would what really
helped as well as yes you are talking
about gas we see the position of germany
which is changing in a positive
direction we see the statements of the
officials german officials that we see
their attitude attempts to find the
alternatives for russian guests but
again
too slow
every hour every a day every night a
civilian a children a child women or
soldiers are dying in ukraine and every
euro or every dollar
given to russian economy goes to russian
military defense system in order to kill
ukrainian people
okay thank you so much for coming on the
program and for
sharing your update on what is happening
in your country we do appreciate it
thank you
thank you
some breaking covered news to bring you
now because the r rate the reproduction
rate in
england has just been published that of
course is the rate at which the virus is
growing anything above one means it is
growing below one it is shrinking and
the england's covert r number is now
estimated
at 1.1
to 1.4 so the r number of covered in
england estimated at 1.1 to
1.4 we know of course that cases have
been increasing in england but also of
course in scotland and wales as well
that our number
just published then
back to ukraine and the first ukrainian
refugees have started to arrive in
britain under their homes for ukraine's
sponsorship scheme more than 150 000
people have applied to welcome
ukrainians into their homes for at least
six months sky's betty cotterell was
with one host as she welcomed a young
woman who'd left her whole life behind
in ukraine
after a nervous wait elena
hello
this was the first time elona from
ukraine met sarah from bedford
they'll now be living together along
with sarah's husband and children
ilona is safe with them but she came
here on her own and this is my husband
saying goodbye to her entire life
you don't understand where you're going
how long time you will be absent in your
family and how long you won't see them
not only on i don't know face time or
something like that and how was it
leaving your husband and your parents
where many speak russian but she knew
she had to get out when a missile
narrowly missed her house
and what would you say to president
putin
sarah will get 350 pounds a month for
looking after ilona but she'd do it for
free she even paid for her flight to the
uk
seeing the
desperation uh
all these people in these families is so
hard
for us to comprehend how they would feel
but you can understand when
somebody needs help elona wants to find
work as soon as possible but maybe she
needs to acclimatise first
she came down this morning wearing a
coat and we're inside
settling in for all of them is going to
be awkward and difficult at times but
this family has given illona a way out
of war and there are millions more who
need that becky cultural sky news
bedford
well as we've been reporting today uh
president biden has
landed in poland air force one to meet
some refugees the 2.2 million refugees
fleeing from ukraine to poland we have
got a little bit of news coming in now
because the airplane carrying the polish
president
who was due to be meeting the u.s
president in eastern poland well that
plane has had to make an emergency
landing after returning to warsaw
the president's adviser was cited as
saying by the state-run news agency on
on friday
the
we are we do understand though that the
polish president did not face any danger
we don't have any more information at
the minute about why that emergency
landing was made but the polish
president there having to return to
warsaw so a potential delay to his
meeting
with president joe biden in eastern
poland
well let's get more now on the u.s
pledge to supply more liquefied natural
gas to the eu to try and reduce europe's
dependence on russia business presenter
in king is in the city and in we've just
been hearing from one of the advisers to
the ukrainian president zelensky saying
how important the sanctions are
against russia every penny given to
russia
going to the war here he was saying and
do you think that the deal struck today
will do very much to try and wean europe
off of the gas supplied by russia
i'm afraid not sophie i think there is
less to this than meets the eye to be
honest obviously it uh it was a very
optimistic and encouraging announcement
uh from uh joe biden and ursula van der
luyn this morning but as i say there's
less to it than you might think to put
it into context europe last year
imported 155 billion cubic meters of
natural gas from russia the vast
majority of that was via pipelines into
countries such as germany just 15
billion cubic meters of that came in the
form of liquefied natural gas now what
uh the us has promised today it was
already going to export some 22 million
cubic meters to europe this year uh it's
offered to add at least 15 billion cubic
meters to that so effectively it's going
to take the place of the liquefied
natural gas that russia was going to
send to the eu it won't of course take
the place of that other gas that was
being piped into europe now joe biden
has promised that by the end of the
decade by 2030 america will be exporting
some 50 billion cubic meters of lng to
europe well that is only a third of the
consumption that europe had from russia
last year so what they promised this
year it's barely going to touch the
sides to be honest there are other
complicating factors as well one is the
lack of lng terminals the number of
terminals in europe that will be able to
accept these imports germany hasn't got
any at the moment olaf schultz the new
german chancellor said on thursday that
uh they would be starting work on two of
those easier but they're unlikely to
come into uh operation until 2026 at the
earliest so no respite there most of the
other countries in europe that have
these lng terminals have only got one or
two there's one in the netherlands
there's one in belgium there's one in
poland greece has got one italy has a
couple but most of them are actually in
spain spain has six lng terminals but
the problem there is that spain only has
one gas pipeline running into france
it's not connected by gas pipelines to
the rest of the eu so it's unlikely to
be able to make much of a difference so
there's a real question as to where
these lng cargoes from america are going
to be loaded and that is a an issue we
have three of them here in the uk
incidentally
but again you know there are questions
over the the ease with which that can be
popped across to europe so that's one
question another one is actually where
this extra american lng is going to come
from because america's lng industry is
more more or less working at full
capacity right now so the probability is
that they're going to have to redirect
lng cargos from other parts of the world
or reallocate lng that the americans had
agreed to sell to some of the others now
the americans probably won't have too
much of a problem with that because
european gas prices are pretty high
compared with elsewhere around the world
so it would potentially mean extra
profitability for the americans but the
question is where that would come from
who they're going to divert supplies
away from the market is pretty tight so
in the meantime the eu is going to have
to try and get under other sources of
energy now earlier this week germany's
finance minister went to qatar they've
struck a deal with qatar to obtain
liquefied natural gas from there but
there are going to be other forms of
energy that are needed to take up the
slack uh in germany's case it will
certainly mean more renewable capacity
but again that takes time to pull on
stream so what germany is likely to do
and germany is really critical here
sophie because it imports uh some 40
percent of its gas from russia it's one
of the more dependent uh of economies on
russia
germany is probably going to have to
wind back plans that angela merkel
announced a decade ago to uh wind down
its nuclear power industry that was
something that angela merkel put in
place after the fukushima disaster in
japan in 2011 she said she wanted
germany to be out of nuclear power by
2022 well the germans may have to
revisit that in the meantime it looks
like they're going to also have to burn
more coal
in thank you very much for putting that
dealer in context thank you in king then
we're looking there at pictures of air
force one that's in poland uh joe biden
president biden of the united states
traveling from brussels where he struck
that deal with the eu that ian king was
just describing
flying to poland where air force one has
now landed
on the tarmac he's going to be visiting
a town on the border with ukraine
meeting some refugees 2.2 million
refugees fleeing ukraine and entering
poland so he's going to be meeting some
refugees there to try and show some
solidarity
with the war-torn country
and to really i guess
show as much as he can that the u.s is
standing with
ukraine at a very difficult time
obviously there's skepticism as ian was
just describing about the impact that
the deal struck today
with eu leaders in brussels will make
when it comes to the sanctions against
russia
he agreed to supply around 15 billion
cubic tons of
gas to the eu but that really does pale
into comparison in the amount that the
europe currently gets from russia only
around 10 there
so some skepticism about whether or not
that deal will make much difference
now the oscars are going to be taking
place in los angeles this weekend and
the war in ukraine is likely to be on
many people's minds as they take to the
stage the ceremonies producers are also
refusing to rule out an appearance by
president zielinski of ukraine and as
our arts and entertainment correspondent
katie spencer reports it wouldn't be the
first time that the event has been used
for political statements
the sunshine state the hollywood glamour
the movie's designed to whisk us away
from reality it's a very long way from
the conflict in ukraine but the war will
no doubt feature at this weekend's
oscars
this is the 94th academy awards and over
the years among the tears triumphs and
total disasters it's long been a
platform for political sentiments so
this year ukraine is likely to colour
the narrative it would be interesting
how they rise to that challenge and they
should in some way i think that's
important i think when you're given that
platform and you know there's so many
eyes of the world watching it then
that's the right place to be
to be um talking about it i'll be
curious to see how much it pops up um
but i have a feeling there's going to be
a lot of love and support for the people
of ukraine uh certainly there's going to
be a lot of
urgency about the climate uh and then i
think mostly people are just going to
celebrate film and story
could this include an appearance by
president vladimir zelinsky given his
background in acting ceremony producer
will packer hasn't ruled it out the
show's still in process um and we're
going to be very thoughtful about how we
acknowledge where we are in the world
but the show's still in process so
that's not something that we would
definitively say one way or another at
this point
at the academy museum it's apparent some
of the most impactful moments in oscar's
history have been those speeches
reflecting the politics of their time
marlon brando won best actor for his
part in the godfather and he chose to
respectfully decline that award and
sense the teen little feather the
treatment of american indians today by
the film industry
excuse me
she was cheered and booed
i think people
know that it's a very
well-watched platform where they can
talk about issues which are important to
them climate change is real it is
happening right now
crucially the oscars offers a stage like
no other to have wage equality once and
for all and equal rights for women in
such tumultuous times impossible to
separate the politics from the party
katie spencer sky news in hollywood
there are of course fears of a hunger
crisis uh sparked by the war in ukraine
and ukraine's agriculture minister has
said that global food prices will
continue to rise if the situation
doesn't change the country is actually
the first world's fifth largest producer
of wheat with 40 sent to africa and the
middle east well joining us now is the
chief executive of action against hunger
jean-michel grande thank you very much
for being with us today um
firstly let's just talk about ukraine
specifically shall we real concerns
about people being cut off from aid food
water how worried
are you about the plight of people who
simply cannot leave these cities
yeah thank you sophie it is indeed
extremely worrying and we we are trying
to find solution about how to go closer
to the population in mario polo on all
these vch areas but as you can imagine
there is there are many challenges in
terms of security and bombing and
but that's our team already trying to
find solutions local solutions trying to
uh to break and looking at corridors
that uh may expect it's a
it's tragic it's a very frustrating
situation as you can imagine as well for
all the humanitarian and the populations
they are trying to help
those in needs
you're talking about looking at the
possibility of corridors
is the reality simply that you just
don't trust russia to keep aid workers
safe
at this stage we will need to have
guarantees and uh there is uh
we we hope that they will be
agreements and that the population will
be able to choose to live or you might
an aid or and you might need to reach
this this population
so far uh i have to say that has not
been the case yet
let's talk a bit more widely shall we i
actually didn't realize how much ukraine
supplied in terms of wheat globally and
can you just give us a bit of context to
that and explain the impact it could
have worldwide
but first of all as you
initially mentioned the
ukraine is the world's fifth largest
producer of wheat in the world and with
40 going to to africa and to the middle
east so now that the port of odessa is
closed for exports
the global staple food prices
like wheat are skyrocketing and
this wall is accelerating a global food
and cost of living crisis so many
won't be afforded to buy the food that
they need for their population to cover
their needs
for countries like
the west african countries we have syria
lebanon lebanon has only 1.5 months of
reserves so today all countries which
are heavily
dependent on on food import are going to
be in very very serious trouble
what can be done to try and help stop
the crisis that could be around the
corner
they are
immediate things and longer term the
image at one are first of all to provide
immediate assistance to the population
which are the most at risk and
especially children who are likely most
likely to be severely malnourished so we
need to act before they become
malnutrition before there is a famine so
it means within the next a couple of
months maximum the second thing the
countries which have
stops of cereals they need to export
more to compensate the loss
of the ukraine production and to
stabilize
the prices and the market the third one
is that western government the donors
government needs to step up their aid to
and their budgets that's the funding to
the to this crisis and not to cut them
or to divert from one crisis to another
on the midterm is just to address
more investment in agriculture and
safety nets that's the mid-term that's
the longer-term solution to prevent and
mitigate crisis let's not forget that we
have similar crisis in 2008 so there are
some lessons to learn from this crisis
and we are still here again at the same
place do you get the sense that western
governments you know the us the uk
are really facing up to the challenge
they are facing up in terms of the
allocation that they are
providing now the concern we have is
that
this money is taken from existing budget
it is not a top-up so it means that this
is done potentially at the expenses of
other crises so we are asking
governments to find additional money
rather than to take it from other crisis
where the needs needs also to be covered
and as we are just saying the needs are
more global and the crisis is going far
beyond the borders of ukraine
unfortunately
certainly far beyond the borders of
ukraine we're actually looking now at
pictures in poland where
president biden of the united states has
just walked off air force one you can
see him
shaking hands with some of the people
who had gathered to meet him there
he's visiting a town on the border to
really show the influx of
refugees that that country has faced
talking about refugees that the numbers
are staggering aren't they about the
population of ukraine uh moving these
refugees and how much of a challenge is
it going to be in places like poland to
keep them fed
i think first of all we need to uh
i have a lot of administration for all
the neighboring countries the polish
population the romanian the moldovan
they have welcomed these the ukrainian
refugees and the world the first floor
of refugees has been welcomed help
assisted by the local communities and
that has been fantastic now we see
a
new flow of refugees those who have less
means less resources no connection no
family relative in in western europe and
these ones are going to stay likely to
stay closer to the border
so for the month a lot
have been introduced but now we can see
in the areas in other areas people who
do not really know where to go they have
little means
and so that's going to be a new phase in
the assistance that is going to be
required
i thank you so much for being with us
we're just seeing joe biden there
stepping
into his car and leaving the plane thank
you very much for being with us and
explaining the crisis there you're
welcome
you're watching at sky news that is all
from me but the united states and the eu
have announced a deal to try and reduce
europe's dependence on russian gas
president biden has now arrived in
poland will have the very latest on that
trip
[Music]
so
[Music]
foreign